oui
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans la
grande interview pour ce nouveau numéro
nous recevons l'une des premières
figurent des gilet jaune souvenez-vous
jacqueline moreau avait été propulsé sur
le devant de la scène après la
publication sur les réseaux sociaux
d'une vidéo elle interpellait emmanuel
macron à propos de la traque des
automobilistes c'était à l'automne 2010
8 aujourd'hui jacqueline moreau a pris
ses distances avec le mouvement
mais poursuit son combat sur le terrain
politique comme candidate à l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22
jacqueline moreau bonjour bonjour merci
de me recevoir
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
sur rt france alors on va bien
évidemment parler des raisons qui vous
poussent à vous présenter à l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22 on va parler
aussi de la gestion de la pandémie en
france les avants si vous le voulez bien
revenons sur les gilets jaunes alors en
cette vidéo qui fait de vous l'une des
premières figures du mouvement
qu'est-ce qu'elle a changé finalement
dans votre vie à bien cette vidéo a
entièrement changé ma vie complètement
redistribué les cartes en fait de ma peu
de la petite vie tranquille que j'avais
avant puisque quand on se pose un peu en
lanceur d'alert obligatoirement il ya
des conséquences
alors il ya des conséquences très
concrètes ma très concrètes déjà toute
ma vie maintenant est orienté politique
alors qu'avant je me je me suis toujours
intéressé mais je n'en faisais pas alors
qu'aujourd'hui je ne fais que ça du
matin au soir
et concrètement aussi et bien ça m'a
appris à vivre avec des menaces de mort
puisque le mouvement des gilets jaunes a
pour moi découlé notamment sur une
branche des gilets jaunes à ma mamie
sous l'emprise de menaces de mort donc
évidemment et bien quand c'est comme ça
et bien on est obligé de s'adapter et de
vivre autrement alors jacqueline moreau
vous vous parliez à l'instant à des
menaces de mort que vous avez reçue
d'une certaines branches des gilets
jaunes les gilets jaunes au début ce
n'était pas un mouvement politique alors
finalement qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
selon vous
je pense que le sens profond du
mouvement des gilets jaunes
c'était d'abord l'interpellation quand
je disais qu'est ce que vous faites du
pognon et bien c'était demandé au
gouvernement
comment se fait-il qu'on est les impôts
les plus élevés d'europe
comment se fait-il qu'on est les
déficits les plus importants
et comment se fait-il que nous dans les
campagnes on n'est même plus de services
publics puisque on voit aujourd'hui que
même la poste veut faire disparaître les
boîtes aux lettres
donc c'était ça le sens profond du
mouvement des gilet jaune c'était dire
bien voilà on paye des impôts et on n'y
arrive plus et on n'a plus droit à rien
et on a plus aucun service
il n'y a plus rien donc il faut
absolument répondre à tout ça et
finalement les revendications ont évolué
au fur et à mesure du mouvement alors
évidemment que il faut voir le mouvement
dans sa globalité je pense c'est à dire
qu' il y avait il ya énormément de
problèmes en france dans toutes les
corporations toutes les corporations
c'est pas spécifique à des salariés à
des patrons non c'est toutes les
corporations donc automatiquement tout
le monde s'est retrouvé sur les
ronds-points pour dire pour venir dire
exactement de quoi il souffrait mais la
réponse n'a toujours pas été apportée
malheureusement alors effectivement le
mouvement des gilets jaunes alors il se
poursuit on voit toujours des gilets
jaunes lors de certaines manifestations
on en voit aussi un parfois beaucoup
moins nombreux c'est vrai qu'avant mais
mais sur les ronds points
qu'est ce que vous retenez vous
aujourd'hui de toute cette période
eh bien je pense que cette période de
toute façon était inévitable c'est
passer par ma vidéo mais ça serait passé
par n'importe quoi d'autre parce que
c'était inévitable
le peuple français si vous voulez était
arrivé au bout de ce qu'il pouvait
supporter donc
et peu importe ce qu'ils auraient fait
ça allait se produire parce que en plus
il ya le ce que j'appelle moi l'air du
temps donc ça allait se produire alors
maintenant ça continue toujours un peu
forcément puisque aucune réponse n'est
apportée à l'origine là justement si
aucune réponse n'est apportée est ce que
attire un mouvement de ce type là peut
ressurgir la alors là on est en pleine
crise sanitaire
on a été confiné les gens c'est
effectivement je vois moi mais est ce
que un mouvement type gilet jaune pour
vous ça peut se reproduire
moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui ça ne peut
pas se reproduire dans l'âme dans
l'ampleur qu'on a connu les réponses
n'étant pas apporté les gens en ont je
peux vous dire que les français en ont
gros sur le coeur
donc ça ne va pas se reproduire parce
qu'on est dans la crise sanitaire et
qu'on est à deux doigts d élection
présidentielle mais c'est justement tout
le tout le sens de la prochaine élection
présidentielle parce que c'est là qu'il
va falloir que les les gens apportent
des réponses et moi je crois que de
toute façon qu'on apporte on ne peut pas
régler les problèmes avec ceux qui les
ont créés c'est impossible de l'alloeu
c'est aussi le sens de ma candidature
alors on va y revenir bien évidemment
sur votre candidature peut être un mot
aussi sur les violences policières
ça a été un marqueur aussi de ce
mouvement dit gilet jaune
elles vous ont révolté toutes ces images
on voyait des forces de l'ordre
finalement tapé des gilets jaunes lors
des manifestations alors évidemment que
moi de toute façon comme je suis non
violente
toutes les violences me révolte
obligatoirement d'où qu'elles viennent
maintenant moi je ne parle pas de
violence policière jeudi qu'il ya des
bavures mais quand on voit si vous
voulez le degré de violence était monté
si haut que il n'ya plus de réponses
correctes qui puisse être apportée quand
on atteint des degrés de violence comme
ça il n'y a plus rien qui peut convenir
dans
donc ni d'un côté ni de l'autre on a on
a mis en face je dirais une branche des
gilets jaunes parce que je parle pas des
gilet jaune du 17 novembre
c'est une autre branche c'est celle dont
je fais partie les non violents qui sont
rentrés chez eux
ensuite il ya eu une autre branche qui
petit à petit s'est laissé emporter dans
la violence assez rapidement d'ailleurs
au bout de quinze jours trois semaines
maintenant comme n'y a pas eu de réponse
cohérente ni du gouvernement ni surtout
à ce moment là de la place beauvau 1
pour diriger correctement et et je
dirais sentir les sens exact de la
révolte qui se passait dans la rue
automatiquement ça dégénère de tous les
côtés le tissu est en train de craquer
alors dans ce contexte là de tensions
entre la police et une partie de la
population il ya ce fameux projet de loi
dit sécurité globale a voulu par le
gouvernement avec un article son article
24 qui est le plus controversé
il a été réécrit début mars par le sénat
mais ses opposants dénoncent une
réécriture de façade
cette idée limiter la diffusion d'image
d'intervention de policiers de gendarmes
en intervention qu'est ce que vous en
pensez est ce que c'est une menace pour
la liberté de la presse selon vous alors
moi je crois que là c'est pareil on n'a
plus aucune mesure on a plus de nuances
on a plus d' équilibre donc
automatiquement ce qui décrit cet
article sont dans des extrêmes et ce
qu'ils ont écrits n'ont pas pris la
mesure de ce qu'ils avaient écrit donc
il faut moi je pense revenir à quelque
chose de beaucoup plus mesurée il
il est clair que s'il n'y avait pas des
la possibilité de filmer en manif est
une manifestation
il ya certaines choses qui seraient
passés à l'as comme on dit qu'ils
n'auraient pas été dévoilée donc ça de
ce côté là filmé en manifestation peut
être bien mais le problème c'est que ça
ne peut pas être en mettant la vie des
gens en danger
ce n'est pas possible dénoncer quelque
chose qui ne va pas par rapport à la loi
c'est une chose
mais mettre la tête des gens sur un
billot c'est une autre alors vous le
disiez par rapport aux mouvements des
gilets jaunes
votre constat c'est qu'il ya ceux qui
sont restés puis il y as eu ensuite qui
sont rentrés chez eux est ce que c'est
pour représenter ceux qui sont rentrés
chez eux à un moment donné que vous vous
présenter à l'élection présidentielle de
2000 22 alors tout à fait moi je reste
convaincu que la majorité des gens en
france et surtout ceux qui ont fait
partie du mouvement des gilets jaunes
sont des gens qui sont non violents qui
sont descendus dans la rue parce qu'il y
avait une réelle souffrance qui est
toujours existante d'ailleurs mais qui
sont rentrés chez eux parce que
évidemment il n'était pas question pour
eux de casser quoi que ce soit mais
alors pardonnez moi je vous coupe la
parole mais tous ceux qui sont restés
tout les gilets jaunes qui sont restés
ne sont pas tous violents non tout à
fait d'accord avec vous ils ne sont pas
tous violents mais il ya une toute
petite minorité qui de toute façon ont
profité de ce mouvement pour y intégrer
la violence parce qu'à la base
évidemment le mouvement des gilets
jaunes c'était des retraités c'était des
salariés c'était des indépendances était
tout le monde s'est retrouvé dans le
mouvement des gilets jaunes et comment
peut-on expliquer qu'au bout de quelques
mois la population s'est retourné contre
le mouvement c'est bien la violence
qu'il a fait ça il a produit alors
pourquoi candidater à la plus haute
fonction de l'état finalement et pas
lors des dernières élections européennes
par exemple vous être engagé dans une
liste portée par le mouvement des gilets
jaunes par exemple certains peut-être
pourrait voir votre candidature
peut-être comme une provocation comme un
buzz c'est quoi votre moteur alors moi
mon moteur c'est la france et les
français donc évidemment que quand je
vois l'état du pays aujourd'hui
honnêtement j'ai mal au coeur jamais je
n'aurais pu penser qu'un jour je verrai
mon pays dans un tel état
donc ça m'incite à m'engager évidemment
pourquoi pas les européennes tout
simplement parce que c'était il n'y
avait rien de près on peut pas s'engager
dans une élection si on n'est pas
préparé on se lance pas la veille pour
le lendemain
donc les élections et européennes je ne
me suis jamais présenté contrairement à
ce qu'il ya eu de colporter à mon égard
je me suis jamais présenté aux
européennes donc une prime près la
présidentielle ça se prépare et moi je
suis en préparation au travail depuis le
mois de septembre de l'année dernière
vous comment est ce que est ce que vous
vous préparer justement depuis le mois
de septembre de l'année dernière à cette
élection présidentielle
alors cessez de la politique du soir au
matin et du matin au soir c'est tout le
temps on se lève on pense politique on
se sent d'or on pense politique c'est on
ne peut pas s'investir là dedans
si c'est pour le faire à moitié donc je
m'intéresse à tous j'ai des conseillers
à l'international j'ai des conseillers
pour tel ou tel dossier
voilà j'ai une petite équipe autour de
moi qui travaille formidablement bien et
en les écoutant j'aimerais les remercier
parce que si je ne vais pas déjà assez
fait parce que une candidature comme ça
ça ça ne se fait pas tout seul on n'est
jamais tout seul alors jacqueline moreau
qu'est ce que disent les habitants de
votre commune par exemple de bohal en
bretagne quand vous leur faites part de
votre candidature à l'élection
présidentielle
eh bien écoutez quand les gens autour de
moi en ont pris connaissance et la
population ici qui me connaît très bien
les gens me félicitent pour mon courage
parce qu'ils me disent vous allez en
prendre plein la tête
effectivement des bâtons dans les roues
y en a tout le temps mais moi je crois
que ça va au delà du courage c'est pour
moi c'est où on aime la france où on a
des tests de toute façon la prochaine
élection c'est ça le clivage c'est ça il
ya ceux qui vont défendre la france et
ceux qui la détestent qui est qu'ils
vont la pourrir parce que c'est ce à
quoi on assiste actuellement
donc moi je fais
partie de ceux qui la défendent pourquoi
vous êtes pourquoi est-ce que vous vous
sentez légitime
et bien tout simplement parce que toutes
ces personnes qui m'ont écrit au moment
des gilets jaunes et d'autres parce
qu'il n'ya pas que des gilets jaunes qui
m'ont écrit évidemment m'ont poussé à le
faire
ils m'ont dit voilà vous devez y aller
on a besoin de quelqu'un comme vous et
bien avec une bonne équipe constituée il
n'y a aucune raison il n'existe aucune
loi en france qui empêche une personne
comme moi d'aller briguer un mandat
présidentiel alors jacqueline moreau
vous restez avec nous on fait une petite
pause et on continue à parler de votre
candidature à la prochaine élection
présidentielle
[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau de la grande
interview si vous nous rejoignez nous
sommes avec eux jacqueline moreau ex
figures des gilets jaunes aujourd'hui
candidate à l'élection présidentielle de
2000 22 et on parle justement de cette
candidature vous nous avez dit que vous
l'ayez représenter les gens du peuple
ordinaire finalement ces gens ordinaires
qu'est ce qui les caractérise
écoutez ce sont des gens qu'on entend
pas ce sont les gens sur qui on met un
mouchoir
et puis qu'on écoute jamais donc et
pourtant c'est la majorité des français
les gens ordinaires
donc moi je je je revendique le fait
d'aller représenter ces personnes là il
n'y a aucune raison pour que plus de la
moitié de la population française ne
soit pas représentée mais comment ça se
fait que cette majorité silencieuse elle
ne soient pas entendus selon vous
aujourd'hui elle ne crie pas assez fort
non c'est parce que je pense que
répondre à la majorité silencieuse ça ne
correspond pas aux politiques menées
depuis des années ça dérange
pourquoi ça dérange simplement parce que
nous on dit la vérité c'est-à-dire que
nous nous sommes là le peuple réel alors
que vivent dans un espèce de une espèce
de virtualité n'est ce pas dans laquelle
personne ne s'y retrouve mais il
continue d'ailleurs on voit bien par
rapport à la situation actuelle qu'
aucune décision n'est prise en
corrélation avec la réalité donc
automatiquement se prendre la réalité en
pleine figure
eh bien ça les gêne ton qui préfèrent
nous ignorer nous mépriser etc etc et
vous vous vous situez où sur l'échiquier
politique vous êtes plutôt à bourges
vous êtes plutôt à droite
alors moi je suis une gaulliste social
donc je suis pour la défense de la
france la défense de la souveraineté
je ne suis pas anti européenne je suis
anti européiste c'est pas du tout la
même chose
c'est à dire eh bien c'est à dire que je
ne suis pas du tout comme emmanuel
macron qui est en train actuellement de
diluer la france pour mieux l'armée
entre les mains d'un futur état européen
dont il se rêve le président voilà donc
moi je suis attaché à notre identité à
notre souveraineté à tout ce qui fait la
france à notre histoire que nous devons
assumer et on n'a pas à venir nous
demander des comptes pour l'histoire qui
s'est passé il ya 500 ans au milan une
france plus souverainiste mais une
france qui redevient ce qu'est la france
l'essence même de la france c'est-à-dire
tout ce que tout ce qu'on a perdu télé
ouais
en tous les cas le tap de votre
programme parce qu'on vit dans une
époque un bien sûr marqué par l'épidémie
avec des perspectives économiques et
sociales très morose on le sait tous
comment est ce qu'on s'en sort pour vous
alors évidemment il ya actuellement en
france il ya énormément de personnes qui
ont de très très bonnes idées mais on ne
les laisse pas émergé bien entendu parce
que toujours ça dérange une certaine
élite qui entend bien garder les rênes
de du pays parce que forcément il en
profite
alors donc oui de quelle bonne idée peut
pour être dérangé les liszt comme vous
l'appelez a bien procédé à une une
refonte de l'état puisque la
actuellement notre notre gros problème
c'est que nous avons une administration
qui est gargantuesque pantagruélique et
qui absorbe en fait tout le travail des
français parce que en gros entre
guillemets ils sont en train de bouffer
tout le pognon des français donc
pourquoi uniquement pour pouvoir écrire
2 3 papier ce que quand on a affaire à
l'administration
c'est inimaginable les lenteurs le
monceau de papier qu'il faut pour
changer une virgule
quand des fois il ne faut pas payer donc
évidemment que tout ça ça va dire ça va
aller déranger puisque ils ont monté un
système en fait qu'il n'est pas du tout
en faveur du peuple
or moi je pense que
la souveraineté c'est le peuple c'est
pas l'administration pendant la danse
est triste sanitaires on a on a beaucoup
entendu
d'ailleurs deux parties de tous bords
des politiques dire que les élus locaux
par exemple n'étaient pas suffisamment
consultés qu'on écoutait pas
suffisamment finalement les élus de
terrain les français c'est ce que vous
avez constaté aussi bien sûr quand vous
discutez avec les maires moi j'ai des
maires dans mon équipe
donc il me parle de tout ça quand vous
discutez avec eux mais ils disent mais
enfin où le par exemple il parle
beaucoup du ministère évidemment
d'olivier ferrand mais ils disent ils
sont complètement à l'ouest
parce qu'ils n'écoutent pas nous sommes
67 millions de français et nous sommes
actuellement dirigé par un conseil de
défense de défense qui fait 5 ou 6
personnes comment voulez vous que ça
fonctionne ça ne peut pas fonctionner et
en plus ça ne peut que attisé cette
fracture est augmentée cette fracture
qui a entre les élites qui nous
gouvernent et le peuple qui subit qui
subit parce que là actuellement on peut
dire que nous sommes carrément
emprisonnés et c'est ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que les décisions elle
pourrait passer par des référendums par
exemple de toute façon moi je suis pour
donner beaucoup plus d'autonomie aux
régions parce que j'estime que qui mieux
que le président de la région bretagne
connaît les problèmes de la bretagne
c'est certainement pas le technocrate
parisien qui sait ce que c'est que de
vivre en plein milieu de brocéliande où
il n'y a même pas la 4g donc voyez et
qui mieux que les corses connaissent les
problèmes corse
donc il faut re de il faut donner de
l'autonomie aux régions est et quand on
a des décisions nationales
il faut écouter ce que les régions à
dire en fait on subit une politique
exclusivement parisienne alors tout tout
est exclusivement parisien donc
automatiquement les gens de syrte ou pas
alors vous vous définissiez tout à leur
commune gaulliste social
la précarité aujourd'hui elle est
grandissante
ça va être ça va être le cas de plus en
plus d'après ce qu'on nous dit comment
est ce qu'on lutte contre cette
précarité des français très concrètement
qu'est ce que vous faites demain si vous
êtes aux plus hautes fonctions de l'état
écoutez c'est simple avec la crise qu'on
est en train de subir je pense que on va
voir à la fin de l'année les les
premiers rapports s'ils ne sont pas
trompés parce que moi je remets toujours
en doute les chiffres parce que c'est
tellement facile de nous mettre dans une
opacité la plus totale quand on va voir
les premiers rapports évidemment que la
précarité a augmenté on va passer de 10
à 12 millions vraisemblablement deux
pays deux personnes pardon qui vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté
donc qu'est ce qu'il faut faire après eh
bien quand yves quand on va relancer le
pays il faut réserver les emplois aux
plus précaires déjà faut commencer par
par s'occuper de deux de nos enfants et
que tu t'es rien de la france comment on
fait on trouve l'argent comment ont il
faut aider les entreprises ça passe par
ou pour vous alors la première j'ai une
politique que j'appelle la politique des
trois piliers premièrement il faut
clarifier les choses
on combat toutes les fraudes mais
clairement on ne fait pas un espèce de
fouillis fouchtra ce que j'appelle moi à
l'assemblée nationale par exemple il
faut absolument mettre la carte vitale
biométrique
enfin ça ça va permettre que les
français arrêtent de payer pour des gens
qui n'habitent même pas en france pas ça
me paraît totalement logique quel pays
au monde accepterait ce qu'on est en
train de payer
enfin on dilapide en fait c'est là
l'argent par les fenêtres et puis et
puis ça continue quand on a 10 à 12
millions de pauvres
non on ne peut pas se permettre une
politique comme ça donc il faut
clarifier d'abord tout ça est créé ce
que dit monsieur charles pratt dans son
cartel des fraudes
il faut créer un véritable
biya pour contrer toutes les fraudes
voilà alors ça s'appellera comme on
voudra mais il faut un bureau pour
contrer ces fraudes
puisqu'on voit quand même bien que on
représente 1% de la population mondiale
et on redistribue 15% et il ya un moment
il faut être logique 1 il faut être
il faut avoir un petit peu plus de
discernement je pense qu'ils en ont un
qui est manuel maquereau en a mais
emmanuel macron c'est un idéologue qui
poursuit un but donc automatiquement ça
m'a pas de la rangée de dire eh bien on
combat les fraudes
évidemment ça fait moins d'électeurs bah
oui mais les français ne peuvent plus
payer les français sont ruinés alors il
nous restera un peu plus de trois
minutes vous aurez l'occasion bien
évidemment on aura l'occasion de
découvrir votre programme dans les
semaines et mois qui viennent
mais pour que vous puissiez de
candidates il vous faut 500 signatures
alors vous en est où et comment est ce
que vous allez financer cette campagne
alors les 500 signatures
j'ai des personnes qui se sont proposés
déjà pour m'aider allez allez trouver à
les récolter
on s'en occupe petit à petit la pour
l'instant la priorité c'était peaufiner
le programme met le site internet en
place
d'ailleurs un petit peu contré hier par
le fait que ovh et brûlés à strasbourg
mais tout est rétablie aujourd'hui donc
il ya des étapes en fait on ne peut pas
s'occuper de tout en même temps donc les
premières étapes sont franchies
ensuite moi je pense qu'il ya une autre
étape qui est très importante c'est le
les élections régionales de fin juin du
mois de juin je sais plus si c'est fin
juin si la date a été défini donc ça ça
va nous donner une véritable indication
sur l'état du pays et est donc ça va
déterminer un petit peu articulée la
campagne qui va qui va en suivre et donc
pour moi la campagne ne débutera
véritablement qu'au mois de septembre
ça veut dire que vous êtes sûrs comme de
vous de vous présenter ou
vous êtes encore en train de vous poser
la question ah non moi je suis sûr après
si par hasard je ne je n'arrive pas à
réunir ses 500 signatures
eh bien je rejoindrai quelqu'un
obligatoirement et vous savez j'ai un
autre candidat et vous avez une idée
non pour l'instant non je n'ai pas
changé
j'ai des préférences et bizarrement ça
serait droite ce serait ce sera de toute
façon je ne peux rejoindre que quelqu'un
qui défendra la france alors il ya ce
fameux débat c'est ces derniers jours
tout le monde prédit déjà un le duel le
fameux duel macron emmanuel macron
contre marine le pen est ce que vous par
exemple vous appelleriez un front
républicain
alors déjà je suis pratiquement persuadé
que le duel macron le pen n'aura pas
lieu
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça que
parce que je peux vous dire que dans la
famille de ceux qui défendent la france
il y à des tractations
il ya comme enfin moi je me dis
aujourd'hui il faut créer une alliance
une alliance populaire de ceux qui
défendent la france ceux qui veulent la
remettre entre les mains d'une europe
qui nous dit lubin
alors là je les laisse à leur
responsabilité c'est pas ces gens là que
je vais rejoindre maintenant moi ceux
qui défendent la france
nous sommes très nombreux et
sérieusement par bonheur et si c'est pas
emmanuel macron où marine le pen se
serait qui vous vous croyez à une figure
qui pourrait se dégager d'ici là moi je
crois que oui il peut y avoir une figure
qui se dégage tout à fait tout à fait
parce qu'ils ne font qu il ne faisait
que vous aimeriez quelques rochelle à 20
mois le profil de toute façon c'est la
défense de de notre identité
puisqu'on voit quand même bien que la
france au delà de tout ce qui ne va pas
en france qui a été le résultat de
de politique menée depuis des dizaines
d'années maintenant c'est notre culture
notre identité
tout ce qui fait que nous sommes
français qui est attaqué donc
automatiquement moi je défends la france
donc j'espère que cette personne
justement ce sera quelqu'un qui défend
la france et non parce que si jamais
c'est quelqu'un d'un autre bord qui
pensent que diluer la france dans une
europe c'est si c'est une personne comme
ça qui arrive à ben alors là c'est fini
la france n'existe plus non là c'est
signé notre arrêt de mort 1
vous nous disait que emmanuel macron lui
ne défendez pas à la france pour vous
marine le pen la défend mieux
écoutez moi j'ai pas lu le programme de
marine le pen elle défend la france sur
le sujet de l'immigration ça c'est clair
maintenant le reste je ne sais pas j'ai
pas épluché son programme
et puis ça si vous voulez y aller
personne mais y aller il ya toutes les
personnes qu'il ya derrière si vous les
gars marine le pen mais y'a les presque
plus de 20% de personnes qui la suivent
donc c'est assez ces gens là il faut
s'intéresser à ces gens là ça va au delà
d'une personne une élection c'est quand
même 46 ou 45 ou 46 millions de français
qui votent donc il faut absolument
s'intéresser s'intéresser et redonner la
dignité à toutes ces personnes parce que
le en fait pourquoi pourquoi tout craque
de partout mais parce que les gens n'ont
plus de dignité
ils sont complètement écrasées on sent
on se moque de la faim dans la gestion
la de ducobu 19 noms se fout de nous
quoi donc il ya un moment il faut que ça
cesse moi je crois que si on ne change
rien rien ne changera
si vous ne changez pas quelque chose
dans un schéma le même schéma se
reproduira et on rechigne là encore pour
cinq ans avec emmanuel macron mon
non je peux pas le croire alors on
arrive au terme de cette émission
néanmoins une dernière question très
courte
si vous êtes élu es ce que vous avez
pensé à votre premier ministre j'ai
quelques petites idées des pistes
oui bien sûr j'ai quelques bas et un
gaulliste évidemment écouter merci
beaucoup jacqueline mot en tout cas
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur rt
frange le rappelle vous êtes candidate à
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22 une
ancienne figure et des gilets jaunes ont
le rappelait cette émission est à revoir
sur notre site
rt france point tv à écouter également
en podcast merci de votre fidélité
à très bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]